RETO MEIER: I'm Reto Meier.
STEPHANIE WONG: And
I'm Stephanie Wong.
Joining us now, Rae Wang,
Security Product Manager
for Google Cloud.
Thanks so much for joining us.
RAE WANG: Thank you.
It's great to be here.
STEPHANIE WONG: So, security is
such a vital part of everything
we do online and in the cloud.
Let's talk about
Security At Scale.
As our environments grow larger,
security simply must keep up.
How is network
security changing as we
move from brittle environments
built on static IPs,
to microservices?
RAE WANG: The traditional
IP-based networking policy
is required to have
very detailed knowledge
on the nitty-gritty parts of
your networking configurations.
They don't really offer you
a concept of which service
can talk to what, unless you
segregate them by IP addresses
and subnets ahead of time.
And this quickly
becomes unwieldy as you
scale your infrastructure,
especially as you introduce
the concept of microservices.
And this is where a
cloud-native platform
like SGO, Automanage,
version CSM,
give a very different
kind of experience.
They allow the admins to
define high-level policies that
focus on application
requirements of business logic.
The microservices are backed
by [INAUDIBLE],, which give you
a natural isolation
boundaries, and each service
is also given a
unique [INAUDIBLE]
of service identity.
Then you can set policies
leveraging these identities
and boundaries.
For example, you can set
to be zero trust by default
between the services, so that
any communication will require
explicit policies, and
then mutual TRS is enforced
by default. And once you
have configured the policies,
CSM can allow you to centrally
manage and monitor and control
Service-to-Service traffic,
and alert any policy violation.
So this is how with a
microservice-focused platform
CSM, it's much
simpler to both create
and do ongoing monitoring of
network security policies.
RETO MEIER: So how does moving
into a hybrid cloud environment
impact security?
RAE WANG: So moving to hybrid
environment, especially
with protocol
Anthos, means you now
have a consistent control plane
between on-prem and cloud.
It gives you a single
admin experience
in a single pane of glass, which
makes it much simpler to have
central visibility and control
across hybrid deployments.
And then you can
also start using
some of the Google
Security capabilities
even for on-prem workloads.
For example, products
like Binary Authorization
or Anthos Config Management
now work for on-prem as well.
And, of course, another benefit
of using hybrid platform
is that helps your workloads
to get cloud ready,
because containers are portable
and the admin may experience
the same.
So when it comes
time to migrate,
it's a very
straightforward process.
And, of course, once your
workloads migrate to cloud,
we offer you additional security
values, things like [INAUDIBLE]
VMs or zero downtime patching
through light migration,
even when there are really
big hardware vulnerabilities,
like Spectre and Meltdown.
STEPHANIE WONG: You mentioned
security consistency.
What are some of
the best practices
to ensure a security
baseline with consistency
and reproducibility for all of
your resources in the cloud?
RAE WANG: Great question.
We know that security is kind
of a shared responsibility.
We do our part and
customers do their parts.
So, in a platform, we offer
a lot of security capability
so that customers can start
on a much higher baseline.
But at the same time,
we also make sure
that your part of responsibility
becomes easy as well,
and that's often down through
templatized deployments,
central config and policy
management, and ongoing
monitoring and learning.
So in terms of deployments,
by using community-style API,
you can express
your configurations
as declarative templates.
Then Anthos Config
Management gives you
a central source of
truth for these templates
and allow you to deploy
the config and policy
updates by GitOps and
[INAUDIBLE] best practices.
These changes then get
deployed to across RFA Clusters
and measures an environment
to ensure consistency.
And when it comes to
constraints, a couple
frameworks, Gatekeeper, policy
controller, and facility config
validators that we're actually
developing the open source
with communities.
They allow admins to
standardize configurations
across your entire organization.
You can, for example, set
guardrails by presubmit checks
in your release pipeline so
that misconfiguration cannot get
into the deployment process.
And then, in case drift
happens in production,
you can also set alerts
so they can get notified.
For monitoring, we also have
Cloud [INAUDIBLE] and Cloud
Security Command Center.
They give you a central
view of the state
of RFA resources in
production and then
can notify you of changes and
risks and security findings
as well.
So, together, these
tools help you
through the lifecycle of
managing your security config
settings.
RETO MEIER: That's fantastic.
Can you talk a little bit
about declarative configs
to make security controls
consistent across scale
diverse environments.
RAE WANG: We all know one of the
most costly mistakes an admin
can make is misconfiguration.
It's almost far too easy
to accidentally set your IM
controls to be to be public or
make your network configuration
to be way too permissive.
And when you do that, you open
up your sensitive resource
to attacks and data leaks.
So this is where the declarative
config makes a difference.
Because it helps the admin
to focus on the end goal,
the end state.
And then allow you to offload
the intermediate orchestration
and workflows and keeping
up consistencies, really,
to the platform.
And then when we do that
across a lot of resources,
across many clusters
and measures,
we basically achieve
reproducibility and recovery
from drift.
And therefore they
reduce the complexity
of applying security controls.
And they also make
it much easier
to share security best
practices because you can deploy
template solutions.
STEPHANIE WONG:
And not only is it
important to
declare the security
configs across
your environments,
but also monitor
inevitable risks.
So we have a big launch,
as you mentioned,
Cloud Security Command Center.
How do we help
customers get visibility
into risk in their environments?
RAE WANG: We're very excited
about Cloud Security Command
Center, because it kind of
unifies the security detections
from Google together with a
lot of the key third party
detections for the
main central place
and really help the admins
to build them, analyze them,
and take actions in place.
For example, one
of the capabilities
is security house analytics.
It scans and detects over
20 common vulnerabilities,
from publicly exposed
storage buckets,
to talk about overly
permissive firewall rules,
to misconfigured Kubernetes
clusters, and so on.
And similarly, you have
Cloud anomaly detection.
It automatically detects
some of the key threats
from cryptojacking to
exposed service credentials,
to outbound DDoS.
And then with this GA release,
another benefit you get
is now Cloud SEC unifies
security findings
from a variety of
Google Cloud products,
from event threat detection
to binary authorization,
to cloud asset inventory,
to [INAUDIBLE] and so on.
How you can use it, well, if
you're in a [INAUDIBLE] company
and you have a finance
department, for example that
stores credit card information
and sensitive personal data,
you can use Cloud SEC to
scan the infrastructure used
for storing these sensitive
information, identifying
your vulnerabilities, as well
as finding active threats that
are targeting these
vulnerabilities.
And then there's
a lot of findings.
So we give you a way to manage
and organize these findings
by attaching business context
to the findings and resources
by our code security marks.
And then we all know
that getting the data
is the first step.
What you really want to do is
to improve your security poster
validator.
So Cloud SEC also allows you
to actually respond to take
actions by, for example,
triggering alerts or creating
[INAUDIBLE] incidents, or
directly executing remediation
operations by cloud functions, .
STEPHANIE WONG:
Great, thanks, Rae.
Your insights into
security will continue
to be vital to any company
that wants to build and grow
quickly.
RAE WANG: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]